alors Afida vraiment il y a un truc je
te dis c'est ça c'est on a fait des
sujets ensemble on se connait tenu sur
le vague au skate depuis 15 ans donc tu
sais que dans cette émission il y a
jamais de piège d'ailleurs que je t'ai
au téléphone tu sais que si tu viens ici
c'est bienveillant
il y a des images contournées récemment
est-ce que tu m'autorises à la passer ah
non surtout pas ok tu sais pourquoi
parce que ça aurait été le meilleur
moyen ok tu veux pas là parce que je
veux pas je veux dire pour voir
je vais vous expliquer quelque chose
et là je suis noir je vais reprendre du
poil de la bête je vais mettre à côté de
toi il se passe un truc
sont les téléphones portables c'est là
la caméra
non
je suis très naturel et sincère je veux
parler au public hein
sont les téléphones je rentre dans un
supermarket je viens de terminer
quasiment les funérailles et la
préparation le deuil de Coolio et de
Ronnie donc j'ai le cœur très lourd je
veux acheter une toute petite bouteille
20 et la dame la caissière me dit je ne
peux pas vous avez pas 18 ans elle est
aveugle je lui dis
j'ai presque 60 ans
c'est une joke elle m'a dit tu n'as pas
ta carte d'identité il y a rien là
qu'est-ce qu'il y en a marre on devient
losers et je suis parti mais en fait
c'est à dire que maintenant on
enregistre les gens et on met des bulles
on met des bulles alors les bulles comme
dans les dans les dessins animés ou à
l'époque les BD elle a dit ça elle a dit
je n'ai même pas prononcé un mot on me
voit partir naturel oh là là il y en a
marre et je pars
je suis victime certainement de
diffamation de fausses informations oui
mais surtout d'un énorme préjudice
qui s'est dit aussi non mais ce qui
s'est passé pardon je parle aux gens ce
qui s'est passé ce qui s'est dit aussi à
qui là c'est que c'était pas non mais
pardon
se dit non mais te le dis parce que
c'est important ce qui s'est passé et ce
qui s'est dit surtout en fait dans cette
dans cette émission c'est que il y avait
pas une mignonnette mais plusieurs
millionnaires que tu n'avais pas ta
carte d'identité mais surtout que ta
carte de crédit n'est pas passée et que
c'est une femme derrière qui s'est
proposée et que quand tu es parti tu as
eu des propos un petit peu antisémites
par rapport au vendeur et les Arabes
vachement chez lui tout simplement dit
mais sur ma cousine américaine black ça
coûte 1 € bien sûr que ça passe rien moi
c'était tellement énervé que j'ai mis ma
carte j'ai retiré la carte et j'ai jeté
la bouteille mais tout ça c'est
diffamation c'est pas vrai je mets toi
tu as dit qu'en fait elle était pas
passée parce que tu avais atteint un
plafond mais pas du tout j'ai pas de
plafond moi j'ai 100000 € sur une carte
normale rien à voir
[Rires]
elle m'a dit je vais te massacrer je
veux que tu t'excuses je lui dis moi je
m'excusais jamais elle m'a dit si tu
t'excuses pas je te black bol sur
internet je dis je ne perdrai jamais ma
dignité
est-ce que c'est vrai que tu as dit
parce que tu pourrais l'avoir dit sous
le coup de la colère et on l'a déjà tous
fait peut-être moi d'ailleurs l'ancien
match de connard est-ce que c'est vrai
que tu as dit tu as sorti ton Instagram
en disant moi j'ai besoin d'une carte
vous savez pas qui je suis je suis une
star j'ai un million de followers
ah non j'ai dit mais j'ai pas 17 ans
j'ai 60 ans espèce de clocharde et j'ai
jeté ma bouteille clocharde
alors tu sais quoi si si tout ça est
vrai j'ai déposé attends si tout ça est
vrai pourquoi tu es interdit l'image
parce que je mon droit à l'image est
énorme j'étais partout il faisait du
buzz et des millions de vues sur une
image qui me portait préjudice et qui
est complètement fausse alors j'ai perdu
Coolio et Rony je n'ai pas besoin de ça
et je trouve que c'est inadmissible
parce qu'au jour d'aujourd'hui les gens
peuvent raconter ce qu'ils veulent sur
vous avec un téléphone on fait des des
bulles comme dans les billes en disant
il a dit si il a dit ça j'espère que
Macron nous regarde j'aimerais que dire
Président chers Président j'aimerais que
vous une loi que tous les gens avec un
portable qui nous filme dans des
endroits publics ou privés soient comme
à Dubaï dans les pays arabes doivent
payer une amende de 5000 euros afin de
respecter notre droit à l'image et un
vélo appeler ça la loi Afida Turner
et crois-moi j'arrive de Los Angeles le
Président nous a entendu
Hafida est-ce qu'il est pas temps là je
suis sincère mais j'aimerais bien tu
sais ce qui m'agace c'est que dès qu'il
y a de la lumière tu fais le chaud
j'adore mais oui mais est-ce qu'il
serait pas temps affinage je vais est-ce
que je peux te donner
triste dès que je peux m'amuser je
m'amuse est-ce que je peux être honnête
ça fait 10 ans et c'est rigolo que tu
chantes Étienne Étienne nürniz bon c'est
pas non plus les applaudissements qui
t'ont rendu sourde tu vois ce que je
veux dire tu as pas non plus fait des
élites et des machins encore c'est en
cours c'est oui mais bon voilà est-ce
qu'il y a pas un moment où tu as envie
tout d'un coup peut-être d'être vrai
est-ce que c'est pas ce que je cherche
des gens c'est drôle le chaud ça fait 20
ans qu'on le voit parce que quand les
histoires
du supermarché de passer du coq à l'âne
alors que je suis en plein d'oeil je
peux dire faut avant
tu sais ce que j'aimerais c'est
aujourd'hui je sais pas si je vais Los
Angeles à Paris j'ai pas beaucoup
d'argent c'est compliqué à Paris si je
fais pas le chaud arrête de faire mon
histoire j'ai pas beaucoup d'argent je
vis à Paris forcément Afida tonnerre tu
veux what the fuck les jeux
personne un jour tu as une choucroute
comme ça un jour elle est comme ça un
jour c'est pauvre tu es riche c'est
normal ça s'appelle life d'Afida Turner
Pender Darling
en même temps tu tu tu es chaud dans la
lumière en fait oui mais c'est mignon
mais en fait tu sais ce qui m'agace
c'est que moi Afida je l'ai vu 10 fois
jamais je répèterai on s'est dit des
choses tellement touchantes parfois dans
ma boîte de production où je t'ai vu
rien qui est un truc qui m'agace Afida
tu es jolie et tu es jeune arrête avec
ces espèces de trucs on dirait si ils
m'ont dit un Casimir ton insta ou tu
parles artistique tu vois mais tu vois
tu peux être un tout petit peu j'aime
bien j'aime bien j'aime bien montrer qui
tu es tu te caches derrière tout mais
pas du tout était pareil
tu es aussi tu es super sensible dans la
vraie vie arrête mais oui mais on n'a
pas toujours envie de montrer ce qu'on
peut
c'est aussi aller un peu de pudeur c'est
un peu le clown triste Afida c'est à
dire que quand tu la vois en loge avec
différentes plateaux mais quand il y a
de la lumière qu'est-ce qu'on attend
c'est le chaud forcément alors je vais
te poser une question très sincère yes
si écoute-moi bien si on te proposait
c'est une main tendue à FIDA yes une
chronique dans une émission qu'est-ce
que tu as peur de sortir du coup une
chronique dans une émission sur C8 ça
voudrait dire que du coup on va pas te
baiser à toi Los Angeles c'est gentil ça
veut dire que tu viens t'installer à
Paris et tu débutes quelque chose bien
sûr avec plaisir ah donc tu reviendras
en France et tu resteras à côté là je
suis en France toute façon c'est un oui
maintenant il faut Louis de Cyril parce
que l'humain n'a pas beaucoup de poids
mais je te remercie beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous et au moins ça veut dire que
tu peux revenir en France